[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACLYN LONG: My
name is Jaclyn Long
and I'm a marriage and
family therapist and a parent
educator.
And I'm also a certified
yoga and mindfulness
teacher and a mom.
And I put all of those
together to create Mind Body
Moms, a company that
helps to promote
health and wellness and
effective communication
and leadership at home
and also at the workplace.
And as a counselor,
I've had hundreds
of parents in my
office say, I really
want to parent differently
than I was parented.
I have great parents.
I love them.
But I'm trying to change.
I'm trying to do
things differently.
And it's really hard.
Why can't I change?
To have this will.
I have this motivation.
I can achieve these
things in my workplace.
How come I can't achieve
this thing that I'm
trying to do so hard at home?
I have this goal.
I'm writing down
what I want to do.
And I can't achieve it.
I can't do it.
So this is something that
I've explored in-depth.
And I've discovered
three things that
get in the way of transforming
the way we raise our kids.
Are you guys interested?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So number one, self-judgment--
when we make mistakes, we
tend to beat ourselves up.
And we're harsh and critical
with ourselves inside.
And that gets in
the way of learning.
It's disintegrating.
Two, lack of community--
especially as
working parents, it's
hard to find the time to build
the kind of community that
can help us learn and grow.
Three, outdated
parenting software--
outdated parenting software.
So what kinds of things can help
us learn and grow as parents
and transform the way
we parent our kids?
Interested?
OK.
One, mindfulness-- we
need to be engaging
in practices that
help us regularly
stay present and awake
and aware in the moment
so we can choose
something different.
We need to be online in order
to choose something different.
And also practices that
encourage self-compassion
and a caring attitude
towards ourselves,
so we can be gentle
with ourselves
when we make mistakes.
Anybody in here not make a
mistake as a parent ever?
So it's inevitable.
We will continue
to make mistakes,
no matter how mindful we are.
And when we do, it's helpful
to be kind to ourselves.
But I've been practicing
mindfulness for over 17 years
now.
And it's still sometimes hard
for me to be kind to myself.
So when I can't muster
self-compassion, what do I do?
That comes to number
two, community.
I need a strong,
robust community
to tap into when
self-judgment comes through.
And we can't find the caring
attitude towards ourselves.
And this self-compassion
is integrating.
It brings together
disparate parts
of ourselves for greater
learning and deeper integration
to promote learning
and growth and change.
And three, which Danielle
is here today to offer you--
updated parenting software--
because most of us
are operating on
parenting software
systems that were installed
in us about 30 years ago.
They're ancient.
And in the last
30 years, there's
been so much discovery,
including Dan Siegel's work--
a whole new field
he's pioneered called
interpersonal
neurobiology, which
brings in lots of
neuroscience research.
We don't even have
MRIs way back when.
So there's also
52 beautiful tools
that Jane Nelson has developed
for positive discipline,
and six elegant, simple,
soulful solutions
that Patty Wipfler with Hand in
Hand Parenting has developed.
That's just in
the last 30 years.
25 years of anecdotal evidence
shows that Patty Wipfler's work
is really helpful to
nurturing children and helping
them become more cooperative
and relaxed in their bodies.
So what we're
offering today, what
Danielle's going
to share with you,
is an updated
parenting software.
And we really want
to encourage you
to not just get this
downloaded into you,
but to be an active
participant in this downloading
process and this installation.
So ask great questions.
Use the Dory.
We will have a time at the
end for your questions.
If some come up
in the middle, we
might put them on the
board for the end.
And also use a really
good filtering system.
So there is no substitute
for your own good thinking
as a parent.
So take what works for you.
And if there's something
that's still not sitting well
with you, just let it go.
No need to struggle with it.
Just let it go.
I hope you enjoy.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
So right now you're
looking at slides,
which is fine.
At some point later
when I talk, I'm
going to be doing
something nonverbally.
And I'll ask you
to follow along.
So we're going to
see what happens.
And I'll do my best to explain
that with language if we
have to when we get there.
Be flexible.
So I'll introduce
myself in a little bit.
But first I want to get
a sense of who's here.
And if we had you in
a day-long workshop,
we would ask what stage
of parenting you're in
and how old your kids are.
And I ask people just
to raise their hands
and take a look
around and see who
you might identify
with like, what's
going on in their household
might be something
like what happens in mine.
And know that if we
had a day with you,
community is so important.
We would give you
that opportunity
to find these people.
And you'd do activities
together and have a chance
to talk more in-depth.
But just out of
curiosity, how many people
here are expecting in their
family their very first child?
You're not quite a parent yet.
And in case there's
anyone watching,
like welcome, welcome.
So if you have a child who
is an infant not yet walking,
raise a hand.
So far that's none here.
So if your children
are preschool-aged.
Let me see.
Oh, we've got a lot of
preschool-aged parents.
OK.
Hands down.
If you have two children.
Yeah, we have a couple with two.
Thank you.
How about elementary-age
children here?
Elementary school?
Yeah.
How about middle school?
No.
High school?
Launched children?
OK, no one with children
out of the house.
Now I'll ask, how many
of you-- raise a hand
if you are parenting in
a way that you notice
is different from the way
your parents parented you.
You just know that
from the get go.
OK.
A lot of people are doing
something a little different.
Thank you, mom and dads.
But we're going to
try something new.
And if you feel like you're
parenting with less support
than you'd like in any capacity,
whether it's babysitting,
food, partner travel,
raise a hand--
you wish you had some support.
Thank you.
OK.
Next slide, please.
Great.
So I'll tell you
a bit about what--
I love this word Flight Plan
that you guys use at Google.
And I'll mix that
with intentions.
So I'm supposed
to, as a presenter,
tell you what I'm going to do,
and then do it, and then tell
you what I did.
I may talk a lot.
I may offer a lot of things.
But at the end of the day,
here's what I hope you get.
I hope you feel that I validated
some feelings and experiences
you have as parents.
OK?
I hope you feel that I
listened to needs that you
have as parents.
I'm going to offer you
some direct experience.
We'll give some information.
But I'm going to prioritize and
value your direct experience.
So I'll invite some mindfulness.
And I'll invite you
to take on some role
plays, what it might be like to
be in the position of a child.
Yeah, and lastly,
two things I'll do--
this is a tremendous
integration for me
to bring together Design
Thinking and parenting
and mindfulness.
I'm going to give
you a map process
to take a Design Thinking model
and apply it to parenthood.
And at the end, I'm gonna
encourage self-compassion.
And I'll say it now.
And I hope I remember
to say it at the end.
If I tell you anything
today, if there's
anything you hear and
you use it to beat up
on yourself as a parent, I
take it all back right now.
So we'll be doing
this kind of stuff
for about a little
less than an hour.
And then we'll have
at least 20 minutes
left for Q&A at the end.
There's this Dory thing
which sounds awesome.
Send your questions.
And if there's something
just completely disruptive
and you've got no
idea, raise a hand.
And Jackie may be able to
come to you as we talk.
So we're going to be sharing
parenting challenges.
And Jackie is going to be typing
these into a nice succinct
list for us.
So it's popcorn style.
And since she's typing,
is it OK if we don't
bring the microphone around?
Are you guys
comfortable with that?
Because people will
be able to see.
OK.
So sharing kinds of parenting
challenges you have.
Anyone willing to be
brave and go first?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Teaching the value of
time to a 6 and 1/2 year old.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Yeah,
so how does that show up
when they're not getting
the value of time?
AUDIENCE: Just busy,
spending 10 minutes,
picking out their most
favorite sock in the morning
and they'll be late
for the classroom.
Or just more little things that
they don't [INAUDIBLE] getting
to school in the morning.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Thank you, and I'll
rely on Jackie to paraphrase.
We have something
related to, they
operate at a different
time schedule than we do.
Who else?
Parenting challenge.
What are situations that
you find challenging?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How helping them to
get through disappointment.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Disappointments.
Yes, so they're emotional
problems and disappointments.
Yes.
yes.
AUDIENCE: Potty training.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Potty training.
Do I have anyone else potty
training going on for them?
I'll raise my hand.
We have that in our house.
In the yellow.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
how to be not manipulated
by others [INAUDIBLE].
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Oh
so they manipulate you
with their emotions.
Got it.
Thank you.
What else do you have?
AUDIENCE: One we had in common
was effective discipline.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Effective discipline.
What happens?
What's the irritating thing
that happens because they
don't have good discipline?
AUDIENCE: Their behavior just
continues and sometimes gets
worse.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Oh, so the
behavior, you want to stop it.
And it keeps going
and it amplifies and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
some way for them
to learn, from
behavior that might not
be what we want them to do.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Got it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Compassion
and growth mindset.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Compassion
What's the problem that you
see because they don't have
compassion or a growth mindset?
AUDIENCE: Mean behavior.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
They're mean sometimes.
To each other or to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, each other.
[INAUDIBLE] bad words sometimes.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: OK you didn't
mention alternative parenting,
but I'm helping to raise some
siblings who have [INAUDIBLE]
the loss of a parent
and just now getting
through their
responses to grief.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Wow.
That's like super
advanced parenting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Thank you, so helping
them navigate pretty significant
emotional growth issues.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] siblings.
And then I'm also
the oldest of eight,
and I raised most
of those myself.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Wow.
Good job.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Anger management.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Anger management.
I have angry kids at home.
What else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Feeling like failures.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Failures.
AUDIENCE: Trying out new things
that are beyond their raw skill
set, but are very good important
skills to have in life.
For example, speaking
out, leadership, or being
more vocal to explain
what things [INAUDIBLE]
their feelings--
explain their feelings,
what's going on in
their mind, and why they
are behaving in certain ways.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Yeah.
Thank you.
You guys are so skillful
at putting these problems
into a solution framework.
That's the next list we're
going to come up with.
I'm like man, you have to go in
reverse to get the problem out.
That's awesome.
There was a hand over here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] how to
not always be the bad cop.
You feel like bad cop.
JACLYN LONG: I'm going to
repeat some of these-- downtime,
trying to find time that's
not over-scheduled--
just for the live stream
folks who can't hear this.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
JACLYN LONG: Because
I can't type any more.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Are
they saying the slides,
the live stream people now?
Oh, got it.
JACLYN LONG: Yes, but
I'm done with the space.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Got it.
So we'll just consider
that place to be done.
And we'll move to the next list.
And in light of the
over scheduling and some
of the time/speed stuff,
and the manipulation--
I'll just mention
some common ones like,
how many people find getting out
the house is sometimes crazy,
or bedtime routines, brushing
teeth, putting on pajamas,
getting in the car and
buckling the stuff.
Yeah, I see a lot of
like smiles and nodding,
like you're all
in the same boat.
So the next list, this is
where we are right now.
Drop of mindfulness--
I had it when you mentioned
the over-scheduling.
I could completely
feel it in my body.
Yeah.
And the next list is
where we want to go.
So I invite you to imagine
your child or children
as a fully functional
person out in society.
And what are the skills
and characteristics
you would hope for them to
have by their early 20s?
You guys have already
mentioned some of them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Emotional
intelligence.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Emotional intelligence.
Thank you.
And since I'm not sure what's
happening in live stream.
I'll be repeating back
what people are saying just
to cover our bases.
What else do you want?
What else do you
want them to have?
You could plant seeds
that are going to grow.
What do you want
them to grow into?
AUDIENCE: Flexibility.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: You
want them flexibility.
Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Respectfulness.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Respectful.
AUDIENCE: Well-adjusted.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Well-adjusted.
Did you have one?
AUDIENCE: Empathy.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Empathy.
AUDIENCE: Contentment.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Contentment, oh yeah.
Yes, in the blue?
AUDIENCE: Healthy
coping mechanisms.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: That'd
be great, wouldn't it?
AUDIENCE: Resilience.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Resilience.
I'm gonna come
back around to you.
AUDIENCE: Sense of community.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Sense of community.
Yup.
Coming back.
AUDIENCE: They're independent
and making the right decisions
on their own.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Make good decisions.
They're independent.
In the very, very back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
So I'm going to
paraphrase and make
a guess that means that they
would feel that there are lots
of ways of being that
are open to them,
that they're not limited
by stereotypes based
on their genders.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Cool.
Thank you.
I'm going to coach you to
notice your reaction to I'm
about to say.
Notice thoughts
that might come up.
Notice if there's a
feeling you have about it,
or if there's a
reaction in your body.
What if I said that
it's the first list that
gets us to the second list?
That it's an experience of those
challenges and problems that
helps develop those life
skills and character traits
in your children.
Kind of a big reframe.
It doesn't make them
any less annoying.
But they can be useful.
We could use them for something.
There's another reframe
I'd like to add in there
related to growth mindset.
And we can start coaching
and modeling for our children
and use these words.
And tell them that mistakes
are opportunities to learn.
And in our better
parenting moments
when we have enough sleep,
and have had coffee,
and we feel up to it, we can
take one of those challenges
as it's happening and
think, this mistake,
this thing that's happening--
this is an opportunity
to learn and to teach
by direct experience
my children how to be,
how to develop these
things on the second list.
And there's another point
I want to make there.
And I usually say this when I
talk to teachers or parents who
want to share mindfulness with
their children or students.
We're parenting and teaching
with a long perspective
in mind, that we're
more concerned
about the characteristics
and life traits
that they'll have
by the time they're
20 than making the
behavior right now stop.
And so with mindfulness,
with children,
I say it's like planting
a seed for an apple tree.
Has anybody here
gardened and planted
an apple tree from a
bare root or a seed?
Yeah, how long did it
take you to get apples?
AUDIENCE: Several years.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Yeah.
It takes years.
So you plant the seed.
And you still have to
water it, the soil.
And so having a patient,
long view of parenting--
and there's a phrase I'll offer.
I'll try to mention
when I'm giving you
a positive discipline mantra.
Beware what works.
You'll get the experience
of this a little bit later.
But sometimes, we can
get behavior change
and get the behavior
we want in a moment,
but it might be out of sync with
a character trait or life skill
we'd like to plant a seed for.
And you'll just
experience that later.
I'm going to do a
check-in on time
and see what I'm going to
do next in our flight plan.
In Positive Discipline,
it's the parenting training
that I have the most
direct experience with.
I also really love hand-in-hand.
We can have a whole long
talk about those two.
And there are others that work.
But I'm going to give you some
Positive Discipline techniques
here.
And in Positive
Discipline, there
are these mental reframes,
like what we just did--
ones related to mistakes
being opportunities
to learn, cultivating growth
mindset, be aware of what
works.
We'll get to connection
before correction.
We'll talk more
about that later.
And we'll, if we have time,
get to this thing called
the mistake and goals chart.
So the reframe-- if my
child is acting out,
a misbehaving child is
a discouraged child.
So my goal in the
moment is to consider,
how do I encourage them?
What is their unspoken
need right now?
And then there
are so many tools.
There's like a deck of cards.
There's an app from
Positive Discipline.
So if you wanted to go on,
you can download that app.
It's cheap.
It's 52 ideas for what
to do with your kids.
And there is a process
I will introduce
later about how you
might pick and choose
which of the many, many tools
to use in a specific situation,
like which one
might be targeted.
Next slide, please.
Here's an example of some
of the positive discipline
tools in a different format.
Some of these are for parents.
Some are for children.
So you've got the positive
discipline tools on the left.
These are tools a parent might
choose to pick up and use.
And on the right, you see some
tools for children and the idea
that they would come up with
their own options for choices--
what to do if they're angry.
And we'll say more about--
the time when they are upset is
not the time to develop these.
I used to share just enough
information when I introduced
myself so that your
conscious mind would say,
this lady maybe has some sense
of what she's talking about.
I'm open to listening to her.
And then I just went on.
And I'm deciding to
open up a little more
and share my
challenges as a parent
from an open and
vulnerable place.
So I'm guessing that
many of you in here
felt that academic and
professional success
either came easily or with
planning and diligent effort.
If that is you, if you feel
like it's you, raise a hand.
If you did that school
thing super great,
if you did the job thing well,
if there was something hard,
you made a plan.
And you did it.
And that was me.
My husband is also an engineer.
My background is in
biomedical engineering.
I did that very well.
I went and I worked in startup
venture-funded medical device
companies as an R&D engineer.
And then I had kids.
And I'm like, I suck at this.
And the worst thing is
I'd read the books--
the sleep method and
the soothing method.
And it was baffling.
For every book I read,
there was another book
that said the opposite.
And I wanted things
to be consistent.
And I wanted there
to be one solution.
Like, what is the formula?
I know myself.
I can just make a plan
if I got the formula.
I'll do this thing.
And it's not like that.
It wasn't in my experience.
My whole thesis was around--
which I wrote many years
after I had children--
how to use the difficulties
in adjusting to early
parenthood for personal
growth and development.
And it was about this time--
I remember so clearly
having a conversation.
I was at a bigger company,
public medical device company,
with production on
multiple continents.
And our director of
operations shared with me
that the most stressful
part of his day
happened before
he left his house.
It was really validating
for me to hear that.
It was weird to have
that conversation
with a man at work.
Because I think it's until this
year of working that I felt
my parenthood was
something I had
to hide in the
professional workplace.
Let me get back to my point.
It's different sharing
from a personal place
instead of just giving you
enough information to trust me.
So I'm here to
give you bad news.
So I went out.
I'm like, OK,
what's the formula?
And I'll do it.
Did parent training, I trained
to become a parent trainer
in Positive Discipline.
I went to graduate school in
marriage and family therapy.
I did more training at
another parenting technique.
I've got a lot of information.
And as I took that
process on, I'm
looking for, what
do I need to do?
And I kept learning that
there's not one thing to do
and that relationships
and people aren't
as easy to put in
a formula as what I
had worked with professionally.
It's kind of scary.
And I've got worse news for you.
The thing I have
learned is being
consistent across
the board, is when
my kids are hot and emotional,
when I am emotional--
when my buttons are
pushed, nothing good
can come of trying to be like--
I can't do parenting.
I can't teach all those
skills and characteristics
in the moment.
I might be able to
navigate that moment
a little more skillfully.
But the parenting
stuff has to just come
and be put on the shelf.
There's actually a
structure of family meetings
you can do every week.
But that's really
frustrating because I wanted
to make that moment go better.
So the bad news is,
there's no formula.
The worst news is, in the
moment when things are hard,
is not the time to do that.
But there is some hope.
There's a process.
And this is where Design
Thinking came to my rescue.
There's a process of
being mindful to what's
happening in the moment,
taking that information,
bring a little bit of parent
training in considering,
how might I redesign
that next time?
Learning some skills to
talk to my children about,
what can we do
differently next time?
If I'm fortunate to
be in a formal class
with other parents,
I can role play that.
I can ask to be in the
position of my child
and tell someone like, could
you please say this thing to me?
And I'll hear it.
And I'll see what that's like.
So you can collect data on
what that would feel like.
And go out and try
it in the real world.
And here's the saving grace.
I don't expect that to work.
I'm running an experiment.
And I'm going to collect data.
And I'm going to
see how it went.
And then I don't have to
give up if it went poorly.
I go back to the drawing
board and say, OK what data
did I get?
Let me think about that.
And I'm going to try again.
So it's this prototype
and iterate process.
It's not this one book that
tells me what's going to work
and what to do.
I'll talk more about this
Design Thinking applied
to parenting a little later.
We'll go through an example.
And let's move to--
So let me just pause a second.
This is a formal
Stanford-designed thinking map.
It fits very well.
What I add-- so I'm coming
from the bottom up with my own
engineering experience--
I'll talk some about that.
If you don't remember this
slide, remember prototype,
prototype think.
And then put some
empathy and mindfulness.
Prototype, prototype, think.
That's the model I
learned in my profession.
And I'm giving you some Positive
Discipline skills dropped in.
And everything's going to be
rooted in both mindfulness
and attachment theory because
I can't put those lenses away
no matter what I do.
I'm going to go through this
map of Positive Discipline
explained by some
concepts from Dan Siegel
a little more quickly so
that we can have more time
to have direct experience.
But the four points I
want to make is that--
oh, let's just go
do [INAUDIBLE].
I'll just do them as we go.
So next slide.
So Name it to Tame it--
that's the mantra
from Dan Siegel.
Here's an example of Positive
Discipline tools we can--
I was gonna say share
with our children.
But it's actually
useful for yourself too.
So if you're having an
emotion, you can map it.
What is the word
for this emotion?
And if you look at
the list of words,
that's a fine-tuning
of-- the columns
are glad, sad, mad, and scared.
But there's tons of other
words that are little nuance
flavors of those emotions.
And so we can share
this with our kids.
And I'll just say that since
this book was published,
there is some FMRI research
that shows people when they're
shown images that would
trigger an emotion,
and their limbic
system is activated.
They have a lot of
activity in the amygdala.
Once they name the emotion
they're having, you can
see a down regulation of
the activity in the amygdala
and the limbic system.
So I like to anecdotally, people
use the tools, and it works.
As a biomedical
engineer, I'm always
curious if I can find
a mechanism of action.
So it just feels good
that those are integrated.
Curiosity questions--
in Positive Discipline,
the mantra is "Ask, don't tell."
And so it puts the child
in the driver's seat.
It gives them responsibility.
We assume that they're going
to be applying thinking to try
to solve their own problems.
And so you would ask them
instead of telling them,
go get your homework done,
or go brush your teeth--
what support would you need
to get your homework done?
You would maybe ask them
to come up with a plan
and set a time to hear
their plan in the future.
For the younger ones with the
teeth, this idea of letting
routines be the
boss, like it's 7:30.
What do we do at 7:30?
What do we do to keep our
teeth clean and fresh?
And so the way we
talk to our children
encourages them to use
both logic and reasoning
and verbal parts
of their brains,
as well as to experience
the emotion they're having.
So we start to
build integration.
Next slide.
Connection before correction.
How many are you familiar with
the Still Face Experiment?
OK.
So these pictures are from
a pretty famous experiment
with parents and young
children, pre-verbal.
And go home and Google
Still Face Experiment.
It's the most uncomfortable
minute and a half of video
you'll see.
So they ask a mom to
come into the lab.
You have normal, nonverbal,
reciprocal interaction
with a pre-verbal child.
Mom's smiling.
Baby's smiling and pointing.
The mom looks.
And then they ask
her to turn away.
And she looks back still
face, not responsive.
Oh, even thinking
about it now makes
my body very uncomfortable.
The child goes through multiple
stages of confusion, upset.
They reach for the mom.
They try to point and
use their usual, come on.
You usually do this.
And then just goes ballistic,
bawls, breaks eye contact
and looks away.
And it's the most
powerful imagery
I've seen about the importance
of nonverbal communication.
We hear that like 70% of all
communication is nonverbal.
And my guess is--
I don't know if there's
research around this--
the communication
with own children,
it's probably higher because
they're so tuned into us.
And our reactions are so key
for their basic survival.
They know us.
And so I'm gonna invite
you to stand up now.
And we're going to
a short activity
around nonverbal communication.
I'm going to find a
place where I think
the most people can see me.
And you're just going to mimic
what I'm doing with my body.
OK, we're gonna do it again.
And I'll add some words.
Eye contact.
You get it.
Yeah, I like that.
Say, eye contact.
I like eye contact.
Facial expression.
AUDIENCE: Facial expression.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Tone of voice
AUDIENCE: Tone of voice.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Body posture.
AUDIENCE: Body posture.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Gestures.
AUDIENCE: Gestures.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Timing.
AUDIENCE: Timing.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Intensity.
AUDIENCE: Intensity.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: OK.
I'll talk a little more.
You can just do the
non-verbals if you want.
So eye contact-- am I
looking at my child?
If they're smaller,
am I on my knees
so I'm making eye contact?
Are my eyes rolling?
Do I look like I'm thinking
about something else?
Facial expression-- is
my face soft and open?
Is my jaw clenched?
Did I walk into this interaction
holding the tension of my day,
and you can see it on my face?
Tone of voice-- do
I sound sarcastic?
Or do I sound curious,
engaged, warm, inviting?
Body posture-- is
my stress showing?
Again, if they're
small, is my posture
down and moving towards them?
Am I held back?
Gestures-- what are my gestures
communicating to my children?
Timing-- it's about,
is this the right time
to have this happening?
Meaning, are people upset?
And we'll do another
activity about that.
Is there a better time to
do what I'm trying to do,
when my child will be more open?
And intensity-- do
I sound passionate?
Do I sound angry?
Do I sound bored and like
I'd rather be somewhere else.
And so we'll do it one
last time together.
And we'll just repeat the words.
Eye contact.
AUDIENCE: Eye contact.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Facial expression.
AUDIENCE: Facial expression.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Tone of voice.
AUDIENCE: Tone of voice.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Body posture.
AUDIENCE: Body posture.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Gestures
AUDIENCE: Gestures.
AUDIENCE: Timing
AUDIENCE: Timing.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Intensity.
AUDIENCE: Intensity.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: And so these
are skills that I would--
if we had you for
a workshop, and we
started to do more
role play, we'd
bring more attention
to and more noticing
of your own non-verbal
communication
and that of your fellow parents.
Thank you.
So timing-- Dan Siegel has
this awesome brain model.
It's called the brain in
the palm of your hand.
And we can do it together.
So stick your hand up.
And it's like your
wrist is the brain stem.
So this keeps our
heart rate steady,
keeps our breathing happening--
basic survival.
Take your thumb and
fold it into your palm.
This is your limbic system
storing emotions, storing
emotional memories,
triggering threat and alert,
beginning the coordination of
a fight or flight response.
Close your fingers down.
Cortex and prefrontal cortex.
And this part right
here in the middle
is the most key for
higher order thinking.
So making sense of emotions,
labeling them, using language,
making good decisions, planning,
envisioning the future.
And notice how this part touches
the limbic system, touches
your thumb, and it comes
back and touches the palm.
It literally physically has
connections to these other two
areas and helps regulate.
Now, there's
something Dan Siegel
calls "flipping your lid."
Take your fingers.
Go like that.
Then put it back down.
So let's imagine--
Can I put you on the spot
for giving a stressful child
interaction moment, a common
one for parents, like--
AUDIENCE: When
you're late for work.
And your kid's not
putting on your shoes.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Yes.
I am late for work.
And my kid's not
putting on their shoes.
That has happened this week.
And so we try to apply
more pressure put on shoes.
And they freak out.
They've just done this.
And depending on how late
we are in our state of mind,
we may have also gone like this.
And so if you see what's leading
right now, what's unregulated,
are these parts of the
brain that you would not
make good decisions with.
You would not lead from this
in your professional lives.
And so there's a concept called
"taking time to feel better."
It's the opposite of time out.
It's also self-care.
So in this moment,
is my child going
to be open to any parent
training I have about being
responsible or timely?
Probably not.
I'll just say for myself--
is my tone of voice
going to be something
warm and inviting and
safe and supportive?
My voice is not in that moment.
And so we all flip our lids.
Our children flip their lids.
I love, there's this
bit of research--
I'll step into this, as a
marriage and family therapist,
I can tell you from
couples research
that once the heart rate
exceeds 100 beats per minute,
the advice is there's not
good communication happening.
People need to step away
and take at least 20 minutes
but no longer than an hour.
There are practices about what
you might do to feel better.
And then you come back
and you talk about it.
They actually sell heart rate
monitors to do this at home.
I kind of wish I would
do the same as a parent.
So we flip our lids.
If we have the ability to step
away and take maybe five, maybe
10 minutes to take
care of ourselves.
In a second, I'll have
you turn to a partner
and maybe say one or two things
you could think of that you
could do in five to 10 minutes
to feel a little better
and down regulate
your physiology.
And when your kids
are not upset,
you can work with them
on a similar list.
Wheel of choice.
What are things you
can do to feel better.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
the moment where
you don't have the five or ten
minutes when you get worked up.
So--
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Survive.
Get through it.
I'll think about that.
And Jackie probably has a
better response in the Q&A.
But yeah, it's not the
time to use the tools,
unless you have use them
and you can reference them.
And let me pause.
Here's what I do
in my household.
There's a certain
threshold that I
will tolerate my
kids being upset,
and we still go
with the process.
And once they peak in emotion,
I will say, you know what?
We're no longer
trying to be on time.
And I'll come.
And I'll break.
And I'll get down.
And I'll give a hug.
And instead of being--
Jackie, could you come
be in front of me?
Perfect.
And you're a kid.
Usually when I'm parenting,
I'm face-to-face right here.
So my son is so sad that I see
this is what he needs right now
is side-to-side.
Or come from front.
I just stop anything
related to the shoes.
This is what's happening.
This is the important
thing in the moment.
Yeah.
Tough morning, huh?
It's OK.
Let's take a break.
And I have two kids.
Anybody with two kids knows
there are sibling issues.
So this is our thing.
I won't do it because
people can't see us.
We actually sit on the floor.
It sucks having a mom who's a
therapist and parent trainer.
Because I make us hold hands.
We sit on the floor.
I make us hold hands.
We don't have to
talk about it yet.
They may not be ready
to talk about it.
But we're in physical contact.
We're breathing again.
And then, it almost sounds
like restorative justice.
I'll let them each talk
about their experience.
And they'll first
try to talk to me.
And I'll coach them, if you
have something say to him,
you can say.
Or just say, I feel.
Because they want me to step
in and declare a winner.
And I step out of that.
So each person gets to talk
about how they're feeling.
And often, we still
get there on time
because that was faster than--
I have scooped the
little four-year-old body
and we're going to the car.
And I forgot to
mention my three lives.
So I do work as a
professional project
manager, an R&D engineer doing
venture-funded medical design.
I'm also a therapist.
And I'm in the school system.
I'm in preschool, and
I'm in third grade
every week for about six hours.
I also do work with students
and adults in groups.
I teach mindfulness.
I do one-on-one .
Counseling and I have a
small private practice
where I see adults,
couples, children.
And then I am over here.
I am lead parent at a
parent participation school.
And my husband is the vice
president of a startup.
And he travels internationally
60% of the time.
And I pick my kids
up most days by four.
I say that not to be like--
no, I'm not Superwoman.
Because I can relate.
I am living that life.
I know what it's like,
both in the parenting
and the professional side.
And I'll tell you,
I brought that up
to mention I'm in
the school system.
And I'm with students
in a class setting.
And I love being with
the three-year-olds
because their emotions
are so raw and so there.
And this process
is very much what
we'll coach the children in
school to deal with each other.
I digress.
JACLYN LONG: I just
want to add that if you
go to mindbodymoms.com
on the home page,
you can click a little button.
And there's a free
video series that you
can look at to explore how to
keep your cool with your kids.
So instead of flipping my
lid in the moment, what can
I do to keep my
cool with my kids?
So that will be a free video
series that we offer you.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: And we're
going to that whole two
minute with a partner.
I'll ring the bell
at one minute--
one or two things that you might
do to keep your cool instead
of flipping your lid in
one of these moments.
JACLYN LONG: Is the
timer still here?
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: So share
with a partner, actually,
one thing you might do to keep
your cool instead of flipping
your lid-- an act of self-care.
And I can't emphasize enough
the importance of modeling this.
If you feel like it's hard
to take care of yourself
instead of taking care of
your kids in the moment,
raise a hand.
Every single person
finds it difficult.
Your inspiration is
that in that moment,
you are now modeling what
you want your child to do.
That's like your excuse.
And you can be
direct about that.
And think about how you
would put that in language
and talk to your
children about it.
And this hand model is something
you can teach even pretty
young children.
And they seem to get it.
This is one of those tools--
I'll point out a
couple of places
where there's something
shareable with your children
to prime you.
Oh yeah, maybe I'll
do that with my kids.
I'll tell them about that.
Next one.
So I'm not going to
talk about all this.
This is just for you to look at.
You read much more
quickly than you listen.
These are the topics
we would cover and go
more in-depth with if
I had you in a workshop
or for parent training.
If you see those
buzzwords on something,
I'd recommend reading it
in your Facebook feed.
And my preference is
to be experiential.
So we try to give you a direct
experience of these concepts.
A little bit of education--
take the ideas, the
latest Facebook read--
let's put that
into an experience.
And then it's no
longer stored up here
with this data overload
and all the things
you ought to remember
when you read once.
I find for myself and
people I work with,
once you've had the
experience, it's
more accessible without having
to spend effort remembering it.
And I'll highlight the top two
we're going to play with next--
so role play and
using mindfulness.
I teach mindfulness to
children and adults.
And in the context
of parent training,
mindfulness is both a
data collection tool--
so interpersonal mindfulness
in this interaction while life
is happening.
What am I thinking?
What am I feeling?
What am I deciding?
And it's also a
tool for self-care.
And that's where some
of the mindfulness
starts to verge more into
relaxation techniques,
but building that trait
mindfulness as well.
So I'll put these
questions on the board
because I'll invite you to refer
to them as we do our next two
activities.
So as we're going to do
it, we're going to do,
what am I thinking?
What am I feeling?
And that means my emotions and
also just raw body sensations.
What am I deciding?
What am I deciding about myself?
What am I deciding
about other people?
The other people's
probably going
to be me because I'm going to
be giving you some commands.
What am I deciding
about the world?
Am I lovable?
Am I good?
Am I bad?
Do they like me?
Are they trustworthy?
Or do they make any sense?
How is the world out there?
Is it safe?
Are there a ton of
support and resources?
Am I going to have
to fend for myself?
And notice, you might even
be aware of a strategy
you're coming up with.
So here's what I'm going
to do so that I can thrive
so that I can get through this
experience for kids that's
often--
here is what I'm thinking,
feeling, and deciding.
Therefore, I must
do this to achieve
significance and
belonging in the world
or some sense of control.
So if you are in
a remote room, I
invite you to play
along just like you
would be here in this room.
And I'm going to
give you commands.
Don't sit down.
Don't look at me.
Don't put your
hands by your side.
Don't close your mouth.
Don't stand up.
Don't open your mouth.
OK.
Find another very confused
partner and talk about this.
What were you thinking,
feeling, and deciding?
We'll give a minute, and
then we'll share as a group.
And coming back to the
group, bring the pearls.
Raise your hands to share
what you guys came up with.
And here, if you're
open, is it OK
if we bring a microphone
so that folks can hear you
in the other rooms?
Thanks, Jackie.
So just raise a hand.
And Jackie will come by.
And you can share
what you guys--
what was your
experience of that?
AUDIENCE: The
expectations were unclear.
That's just one point.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
So in that moment,
what were you thinking
or feeling about me?
AUDIENCE: I didn't know what
you wanted us to do, so--
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Or yourself?
Was there anything there?
AUDIENCE: Confused.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Confused.
How many people were confused?
Yeah.
Super common experience,
very human, common humanity.
Other sharing, what
did you guys notice?
We have one in the front.
Oh, she'll come
back to you next.
I need to receive support.
Jackie's going to do
the microphone thing.
AUDIENCE: I just had
a rebellious reaction.
For some reason, when somebody
tells me to do something,
I'm just like--
and I felt neutral.
I almost said, I'm not
going to do either thing.
I have no interest.
It was just almost like that
was the rebellion was just
shut down and not allow the
other person to have power.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: How many
people notice rebellion?
That is my go-to in this
exercise, happens to me.
Yeah, thanks.
In the red hat, we had one.
AUDIENCE: It felt
like somebody is
trying to boss me and tell
me exactly what to do,
what not to do, and [INAUDIBLE]
like my little 3-year-old
sometimes when she gets mad, she
just, Papa put me in your lap.
Papa, stand up.
Papa, walk like this, Papa.
Hold me with one hand
and walk like this.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Oh, so she tell you.
AUDIENCE: She does.
She does that.
And we'll tell her, you
can't boss Daddy like that.
You can tell Daddy,
hug me, kiss me.
But you can't say, walk.
Stand on one foot.
Hold me in your lap and run.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Bossed around.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: We
have another-- yeah,
they felt bossed.
Another Person ditto for that.
OK so we're gonna do this again.
Stand up.
Look at another person.
Raise your hand.
Open your mouth.
Clap your hands.
Sit down.
Same thing with a partner.
Go ahead and share
with a partner.
And then we'll
share as the group.
So what was your
experience of that one?
AUDIENCE: So we
felt less confused
because the second
set of instructions
were more positive, meaning
the previous ones were all
don't do this.
Don't do that.
Don't look here.
Don't lift your hand.
These are all, do this.
Do that.
Look at me.
Look at this one, et cetera.
So the tone was more
positive, I think
So it felt less confusing.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Positive and more clear.
AUDIENCE: Yes, since I
knew what was coming,
I didn't feel like
following the instructions.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Oh, because
you knew it was happening,
you were like, I
don't want to do this.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I said,
it didn't make sense.
So why should I follow?
I don't know why
I thought, but--
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
I hope you're not
bored with it yes.
I invite you to stand up.
I invite you to look
at another person.
I invite you to raise your hand.
I invite you to open your mouth.
I invite you to
close your mouth.
What do we need to do next
to share with a partner?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: I
invite you to sit down.
And I invite you to
share with our partner
briefly about that experience.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: And we
can start sharing now too.
So let's do first
that experience.
And then we'll put it together.
AUDIENCE: Seemed that this was
even more positive because now
you're inviting us to do it.
And we actually felt
this was more fun almost.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: So I'll
ask by raise of hands.
How many people found the
first one to be both confusing
and they didn't want to do it--
when I told you what not to do?
So confusing--
JACLYN LONG: Almost everyone
is saying their hands.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Thank you, Jackie.
Second one, how many people felt
a little more open to doing it?
It was more clear, and they felt
a little more willing to listen
to what I was asking.
JACLYN LONG: Most of
the hands are raised.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Most of hands.
And for the third
one, if you thought
it was even better
than the middle one
when you had an invitation.
Yeah.
Most hands.
How many of you felt a
little more willing to do it?
Yeah, I wish I could Dr.
Spock myself and remove
all my non-verbals and
be 100% consistent.
I'm aware that I'm
not perfect at that.
So that probably
clouded your experience.
So just a little bit
of insight as parents,
what are you taking away
from this experience?
And just again, because
we have people listening
who won't hear you, we'll
bring you the microphone
if you're willing to share.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
At some point if you really
want them to do something,
at least talk it in a positive
and respectful way so that
at least they feel you aren't
just trying to boss them or--
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thanks.
JACLYN LONG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I think
it's important to make
your expectations
clear about what
it is that you want them to do.
AUDIENCE: I felt like
the final way felt,
it was more like you're
on the same level--
like as a friend
would invite you
as opposed to being on a
different level where you're
commanding somebody.
So I don't know.
It made me feel more like
we're part of the same team
or whatever.
And I'm trying to relate it to
a family member, like you're--
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was interesting
because the command was direct.
And it was saying, you
don't have an option.
And then you can say,
here's just a directive.
And then the third one actually
takes more emotional risk
because you're giving
the child agency.
And you're inviting
them to say, yes or no.
I thought it was interesting
that the reactions were
opposite to your intention is--
you have to do this.
And my reaction is no.
And you're saying, I
invite you to do this.
I could say no, but
my reaction was yes.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Did you notice
in that third less rebellion?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Yes, absolutely,
which was interesting
because I could have
battled if I wanted to.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Absolutely
AUDIENCE: But I didn't have that
agency, well, realistically.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
We're just sitting.
That's totally fine.
You can just sit in the chair.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
JACLYN LONG: So a little
transparency here.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you,
I was about to say that.
JACLYN LONG: We
actually just were
inspired to do a little
design thinking live.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: We just
made that last part up.
JACLYN LONG: We
just threw that in,
in part because of
your experience.
When I heard that
rebelliousness, which
I relate to, we
wanted to throw in,
what would happen
if we invited them.
So I also was thinking
about doing this because--
it came to me just now because
in the therapist room when
I work with couples, I sometimes
get a wave of something that
could be helpful for
one of the partners
to say or do with
the other partner.
And if I say, please turn to
your partner and say this,
they'll usually be
a little non-verbal
like, I don't want to.
But if I say, would you be
willing to turn to your partner
and say this?
Almost always, they're,
yes, I would be willing.
So when we take a moment to
invite or ask for willingness,
it really can help that
rebellious piece soften.
And this actually comes from
nonviolent communication.
So I invite you to look more
into that if you're interested.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Thank you, Jackie.
You even had that with you.
JACLYN LONG: Yes.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank
you for playing along.
To step into some
role play, I realize
asking people to step a little
outside normal comfort zone.
And if you're in
a separate room,
I encourage you, please do it.
If you didn't do the last
one, do this next one.
We're giving you things on a
very shallow side of the pool
of parenting experientials.
What I'll describe
a little later where
you start to like
take on role playing
situations in your own
life, that's the deep end.
I appreciate that
these experiences are,
they're very light
and very brief.
They evoke very real responses,
especially when you're
paying mindful attention.
You can be aware of a
really quick response
in the body, or the thoughts,
or reaction tendency.
So you're going to find
a partner and the person
with the birthday that comes up
next is going to make a fist.
And so find your partner.
The person who has the
next birthday makes a fist.
When I see people
with fists, I'll
know that we're ready to go
with the next instructions.
So people with the fists--
your job, at least at the
beginning of this exercise,
is to be a little resistant.
And no matter what,
you are not going
to open your fist in the first
10 seconds of this thing.
And then after a while, you
can decide what you want to do.
Other partner, your job,
without touching them,
is to get them to
open their fist.
And you're both being mindful.
What am I thinking,
feeling, deciding?
What do I really
want to do here?
Any questions?
Go.
Get those open.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Do
not open your fist yet,
not yet, no matter what.
Get those fists open.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JACLYN LONG: You're
entering that choice period.
If you feel inclined to
open your fist, you can.
Still getting fists.
Oh, I see a hand shake up here.
I wonder what that's about.
I'm very curious.
I notice the volume is
getting a little louder.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
JACLYN LONG: And
thank your partner.
And you are no longer
doing this exercise.
You're now just talking to
your partner about how that was
and what you noticed
for yourself.
AUDIENCE: So I could
relate to the experience
we had because we started
by trying to reason.
And there was some
attempts at logic.
And then it quickly went all the
way down to bribery at the end.
And that's the thing that
worked in this situation.
I don't know long-term.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
How many people
have used that
tactic as a parent--
reasoning turned to bribery?
Cool.
AUDIENCE: I had an
interesting thought
that you just taught us inviting
and asking for willingness.
And I could've used it.
But I said, no, I'll save
whatever I learned for later.
Why should I save it for later?
I could've use that right here.
It's all because you
accumulate wealth or knowledge.
You save everything for later.
Let me use it later.
Let me save this PDF
and read it later.
You accumulate and
use it for later.
Can't you use it right away?
I mean, you have situations.
But you don't realize that
you can use it right away.
That's probably because
you're not mindful enough.
That could be something.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Did he open his hand?
AUDIENCE: Oh he did.
I just said, could you drop it?
So that's what--
I could have used a better
tone and tenor to get it done.
But I didn't do it as well.
I guess that's something that I
have to use late in the evening
and as I go home,
or in the upcoming
meetings as well, that
we have in the afternoon.
Use that phrase right away
instead of saving it for later.
So that's something
that I realized just now
through this exercise.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was interesting
because as I was being
asked to unfold my hand,
and it was more
and more of like,
can you just try this tactic?
I realized, I must have
something pretty valuable here,
and its control.
I just though it was
really interesting.
I felt like I had power.
And I was like, I'm not
letting this go in this moment.
I mean, the kids don't have a
lot of power, realistically.
And even little things,
you hold onto that.
and I can remember
being like that myself.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: Thank you.
So you can see just from
these two very quick role
plays how much you can step
into the world of your children
and how much you can
step into the world
of a parent with a mindful
lens and gather some data
and insight.
Oh, thank you.
Jackie already-- can we
switch to the slides?
How do we do that?
I think she's figured that out.
So when we do role
play work as parents--
so this is the OK,
so it's not all lost.
There's not a formula.
There's not one
right thing to do.
But there's a
process of choosing--
let's choose.
In my therapy training,
cognitive behavioral work,
it's called the one grain
of sand in the hourglass.
And we pick one
instance in time.
And I'm going to treat it like
a story, like a narrative.
If a surgeon came
to me, and they
want to design a new
medical product--
walk me through
what's the procedure.
Walk me through the
procedural step.
preparation, the use of it,
and so you see what
the needs are clearly.
And then as a parent,
if you're in a group
with people who you
can role play with,
I highly recommend it.
If you're not,
you can go through
and take an empathetic lens.
What do I think my
child might be feeling?
If I were in a
similar situation,
what are the thoughts and
feelings I might have?
And you can definitely
do it for yourself.
And again, mindfulness is
your data collection tool.
So what kinds of solutions
might be most helpful?
How did that solution work out?
In my engineering
world, I'm going
to create my first prototype.
I'm gonna do it very quickly.
I'm not going to
overly think it.
As soon as possible, I'm
going to get something
into a physician's hands.
And they can try it.
And they can give me feedback.
In a perfect world, I can
go, and I can watch it.
And so I can even learn all
the things they didn't say.
So it's important to
prototype and test.
So you go home, and you're
testing it on your kids.
And treat it like an experiment.
You don't know exactly how
it's going to turn out.
But you're going to stay awake.
Interpersonal mindfulness
with your children--
holding both yourself and
them and their experience
at the same time.
And then when you're
with a group of parents,
you get a chance to
role play before you
go out and do it live.
I call it bench testing before
you go do in vivo testing.
I don't want to set a
prototype to a physician
if I haven't even tried it.
I try to mock up the
physiology the best I can,
see how it works.
It's what we do in
our parenting groups.
You can decide to play
yourself or your child.
And you can even assign
people to the other folks
who are in the room--
other children, a partner.
And you go in and just the
same questions I asked you--
what are you thinking?
What are you feeling?
What are you deciding?
You go around.
You get insight.
You gather data
from each person.
Then you go, OK.
Let me jump into tools and
jump into brainstorming.
And I put the
participant in what's
called the "cone of
silence" because there's
a way we have of supporting
parents and talking
to each other.
We want to figure it out.
Well, have you tried this?
What's going on with your child?
So we'll literally
suggest the person turn
and look where
I'm writing notes.
And people are talking to
another person and just
recording ideas to brainstorm.
Every idea is valuable.
Make a huge list.
And we make sure
that we put a couple
of the Positive
Discipline practices
we just learned on there.
And then the person gets to
choose one they'd like to try.
They can play it again,
this time as themself,
see how it went, and
then you take it out
into the real world.
And then the beautiful
thing is they'll report back
on, how did that go?
And everybody's curious
until the next week,
like, I don't know.
What was the response?
And mindfulness--
we're not assuming it's
going to be positive.
We're going to notice what is.
We're just going to
collect the data as it is.
Anything else about--
let's go to the next slide.
So you can see, I
mentioned there's a map.
The mistaken goals chart?
Cool.
There's a map of ways to think
about your child's hidden needs
and mistaken goals and what
tools might be helpful.
And it starts with imagining
that one grain of sand
in an hour glass.
Let's think about one thing.
Let me play it in my
mind like a movie.
Or go out, and I'm
experiencing, what am I feeling?
What's my feeling right now?
So take a look at this chart.
Start with the
Parent Feels column.
It doesn't have to
be the perfect--
just be any difficult
situation with your child.
Maybe this morning, maybe
last night at bedtime--
think if you could see which
row of feelings, which category?
Did you feel more annoyed,
irritated, worried, or guilty?
Did you feel angry, challenged?
Did you feel hurt
or disappointed?
Did you feel
despair or hopeless?
For yourself, read
across that one row.
We don't have time
to go into this.
But read across that row and
take in that possibility.
There's never any assumption
that this is right.
Again, we'll apply that lens
and see what comes out of it.
So I actually brought
with me this dove thing
I did with first graders
a couple of weeks ago.
It shows this idea
that mindfulness--
first, my definition that I
like is the Jon Kabat-Zinn
definition.
He founded the mindfulness-based
stress reduction.
Mindfulness is just
paying attention
to the present moment on
purpose nonjudgmentally.
When I talk to
kids, nonjudgemental
is a conceptual--
I tell them being OK.
You have an open mind and
a kind heart about it.
And so there are these
two aspects we already
talked about in the definition.
But I like the visual imagery.
And kids like to draw too.
So think about two
wings of a bird.
It won't fly unless it has both.
On one side, you're
increasing awareness
under a little magnifying
glass and a little leaf.
And on the other side,
there's this feeling
of heartfulness and this
nonjudgmental attitude
towards what you're seeing.
And I wish I could make this
visual happen right now.
If you can imagine
this little heart
I drew getting huge
right in front of me
and put in that self-compassion
for yourself as a parent.
So you're noticing the
experience of a parent
can be tough.
I will warn you, as you
become more mindful,
you're more mindful of those
joyous moments that aren't
the over-scheduled structure.
But you increase your
awareness of the gaps
and the unpleasant feelings too.
And then, how do you hold that?
What do you do with that?
Kristin Neff-- I love her
model of self-compassion.
One, experience what
it is and allow it.
I'm gonna allow this experience.
Recognize this common humanity.
You know, another
reasonable person
in this experience
as a parent, they
might feel the same way too.
I am not the first
person to feel this way.
I hope you got an experience
of that in the room just--
when people start laughing,
I think it's happening.
And you have compassion
for yourself,
and you treat yourself kindly.
So shall we skip meditation
in favor of some Q&A?
JACLYN LONG: Sure.
And I think that's
a nice place for me
to just read a little poem.
I really enjoy offering
poetry when I teach.
So this feels like it
would come nicely off
of Danielle's information
around mindfulness
and self-compassion.
And it's called "The Window."
I was getting ready to go
to work to give a lecture.
I was putting my notes in my
briefcase when the ball came
through the window.
And the glass went flying--
a million tiny pieces
all over the living room.
In that moment, I felt
my anger grow inside--
my frustration at
the house never
being organized enough; the
expense of the window getting
repaired; and living, for
a while, with cardboard
or plywood to replace the
glass; the thought of,
how will we ever clean
up all the glass?
And I became angrier
still as I now
knew I would be late
for my presentation.
I heard your small four-year-old
feet running up the steps.
I saw your tiny arm
push open the door.
Your eyes locked on mine--
moist, searching.
In that moment, history changed.
I took you in my arms.
Are you hurt?
It's only a window.
That can be replaced.
That you are not hurt is
what's important to me.
It's only glass.
And you are my son.
I love you.
Let's get the broom--
Bruce Linton.
What I like about that is,
I'll just say real quickly,
this recognition in the middle.
He's aware of his anger.
He's feeling my
frustration growing inside.
So there's this idea that
this person, this dad,
is aware of himself.
He's noticing the anger growing.
That capacity for witnessing
ourselves in the moment helps--
helps with this
question of, what
do you do if you're
about to flip your lid
and you don't have five minutes?
These moments of just noticing,
ah, naming frustration.
Frustration can help.
And then also not only
noticing what's in me,
but noticing the size
of our little ones,
noticing how little they
are, noticing their eyes,
noticing how their body
responds to our bodies.
That's helpful.
And I also love this
experience of "in this moment,
history changed."
This is a moment of
updating our software,
updating our internal software
by doing something different.
OK, thanks.
We'll take your questions.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
There are a couple here
that were voiced from
people watching remotely.
The first one, how
do we educate a child
that there are
sometimes failures
and we should just
learn from it?
They gave an example of
having a six-year-old who
almost always cries if they
don't win on a card game.
And this parent's OK allowing
the child to win every time
but worries if they're
teaching he can always win.
And so allowing the
experience, do not
make the feeling go away,
supporting through it,
giving the language of mistakes
are opportunities to learn.
And it's so powerful when
you bring in modeling.
I know some people who go
around the dinner table.
They'll go and share what
mistakes they made for the day.
So you can model your
reaction to your own mistakes.
How do you motivate
a young child
to complete tasks like eating
and getting ready for school?
Lots of ways to do it.
I'll mention a
Positive Discipline
tool would be to come up
with a routine together.
And so, you can just,
what's next in your routine?
And so you can point back to
the routine running the morning.
So you're not this bossypants
telling the kid what to do.
We have a sense of control.
And as much as they can,
they come up with a routine.
What do you need to do to
get ready in the morning?
You don't top-down it.
You support them
side-to-side in coming up
with their own schedule.
And
At what age do you
suggest parents
begin to try mindfulness
activities with children?
What could you do
with a two-year-old,
a five-year-old, a 10-year-old?
I feel like that
gives me permission
to do the mindfulness
practice we
were going to do because
it's something I have--
oh, this is David's.
That's why Jackie's looking at
me with a strange expression.
So these balls are wonderful.
I forget what they call--
Hoberman.
Does that sound right?
So this borders on relaxation.
You're not just
noticing what is.
You're making something happen.
And this is going to
take charge of breathing.
There's some
rationale behind this.
As you start to
exhale more, you tend
to have more
parasympathetic relaxation.
And a kid doesn't have
to be able to count.
They're going to inhale
as I open this and exhale
as I close it.
For those of you who
you want to count along,
inhaling to one, two, three,
four; exhaling to one,
two, three, four, five, six.
And you can keep
looking up here.
Jackie, can you time
us for one minute?
Let me know when
a minute's over.
My timer's over
here on this chair.
Four, exhaling, one, two,
three, four, five, six.
JACLYN LONG: Just do it more
time, just a whole minute.
Is that OK with you?
DANIELLE SEYBOLD:
Can I do three more?
JACLYN LONG: Sure.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: OK.
Just notice your own
body and if there's
any effect of just doing a
very short little practice.
And I mentioned there's
a new book that came out
called "Mindful Games."
It's got like 60
examples of games
you can do with
very young children.
You could check that
out for some ideas
of how to share this
with a young audience.
JACLYN LONG: And the
question was to what age?
What's the best--
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: So I
have done that literally
with first graders,
and they loved it.
It was much easier
than other techniques.
I would do it with
my four-year-old too
and to set the expectation
of what their practice will
look like and give them the
permission to have whatever
experience they have of that.
JACLYN LONG: Right.
DANIELLE SEYBOLD: It is 1:30.
I tend to be very time-oriented.
I'm OK if we extend to do
some more Q&A for like 5
to 10 minutes be OK, or?
AUDIENCE: I just want to
take one minute before--
JACLYN LONG: And also, those
of you who are in the room,
if you want to write
down your email
addresses if you
want to stay in touch
so you can be informed of
other offerings that we have,
Danielle is going to be offering
a couple's communication
workshop in August.
One day is on couples
communication.
And the next day is on
Positive Discipline.
So if you want to get into
the same page as your partner,
this is a really great
opportunity to do that.
We're also trying to ask
a dear friend of mine who
does outdoor education
with kids to do
a camp during the
day for the kiddos
so that kids can be in camp,
and the parents can get support.
Really excited about that.
And if you want more
information about that,
that's on mindbodymoms.com
Thinking of other things
that might be relevant--
in 2018, we just lead a yoga and
mindfulness and surfing retreat
in Costa Rica.
And before I had my son, I
used to lead family retreats
internationally.
And we're thinking of
doing that again in 2018
to have a family retreat
abroad, so stay tuned if you
want to stay connected to us.
Or write your email address.
We ask you to
actually read it twice
because usually we get letters
or numbers that we don't
know if it's a four or an h.
So if you can write
your email twice,
that will help us stay in touch.
I want to go back to one of
the questions about competition
and having a hard time
with losing a game.
In my practice when I was just
beginning to work with kids,
and kids would come in
and the parents would say,
he can't deal with
not winning this game.
He flips out.
He has a major
tantrum every time.
I would usually begin by
helping him, coach him.
And we'd play a game.
And I'd say, see this
is how you like--
I was modeling
good sportsmanship.
And it didn't really
have any effect.
One of my mentors,
Larry Cohen, who
wrote "The Art of Roughhousing
and Playful Parenting"
said something that was like,
I would never do with a client.
He said, OK, you're doing
positive role modeling, that's
fine.
Do the opposite.
I say, what do you
mean, do the opposite?
And he said, model
a really poor loser.
I said, how would that help?
How would modeling
poor losing help?
So I thought about it.
And I just gave it
a shot one time.
And I modeled poor losing.
And I modeled poor losing in
a really overly dramatic way.
And the parent was like,
what did you do in that room?
The next day he was fine.
He could play a game.
And he didn't even care
that he was losing.
What did you do?
So I started
exploring this more.
And then that fast
forward taking work
with Patty Wipfler in
Hand in Hand Parenting,
she has a concept
called "Play Listening."
And Play Listening means you
are the goofy, incompetent one.
And you can't seem
to do their thing.
So when my son was learning to
walk, I would walk over to him.
And I'd fall and
trip on the floor.
And he'd laugh and
laugh and laugh.
And what it does, is
it offloads tension.
This is the theory-- it offloads
tension and anxiety that's
built up in the system by
not being able to do things.
So in this case,
the thing that's
not being able to
be done well is
losing with good sportsmanship.
So I am then modeling losing
with poor sportsmanship
in an overly dramatic way.
I can't figure out how to
lose and feel OK about it.
I wanted to win.
So I'm throwing
this big tantrum.
The other thing
that I'm doing that,
as my therapist cap
comes on to explain,
like why would this work--
is externalization.
So there's this
issue he's having
inside of him of not being
able to handle losing well.
And I'm propping it out of
him and putting it into me.
It's like cinema therapy,
or like drama therapy.
Now it's in me at a
distance from him.
And he can see it.
And he be like, oh my
god, that's so uncool.
So usually what
will happen when I
start having this big
tantrum around losing
is the kid will come
up to me and say look,
it's not that big of a deal.
Why are you acting that way?
Stop.
Relax.
It's fine.
It's just a game.
And they coach me.
So it's out of them, and
they start coaching me.
So I know this is highly
counter-intuitive.
And like me, you probably
will be like, well,
I'm not going to do that.
That's just ridiculous.
But if you give it
a shot, I encourage
you to practice Design Thinking
and see if it might work.
It's helped a lot of kids that
I've worked with really stuck
with competition, really having
a hard time with losing well.
I'll close with one
last inspiration here.
So in the Boston Globe
probably over 20 years ago,
there was this discussion on
egg banks and sperm banks.
And so some Nobel Laureate
wrote in and said,
we should gather sperm banks.
And all of the people who
become Nobel Laureates,
we should get sperm from them
and create these really smart
people out of them.
And a feminist
wrote in and said,
well, if there's
sperm banks there
should be egg banks, of course.
And a Nobel Laureate
from Harvard
wrote in and said, forget
sperm banks and egg banks.
Just practice loving.
How do you think one ends
up as a Nobel Laureate?
By wanting love, that's how.
By wanting it so badly,
one worked so hard,
and ends up a Nobel Laureate.
But it's a consolation prize.
So instead of thinking about
sperm banks and egg banks,
just practice loving.
Love a Russian, a Jew--
not just people
here, but everywhere.
So we hope that
of all the things
that you've learned
today, you'll
learn that this
is all about love.
This is about
practicing loving--
loving, respectful
relationships with our kids
that's mixed with firmness.
So Danielle teaches about
kind and firm parenting.
Both are important.
AUDIENCE: I had so
much fun with you guys.
I love being with a
group of people who are
interested in the same things.
And this is a great way to
spend a middle of the day.
Yeah.
Thank you for engaging
in and being here.
Best of luck.
[APPLAUSE]